if you go through life always taking the
path of inaction always opening these
Loops wondering whether or not the girl
on the tube was single whether or not
your boss would have given you a pay
rise whether or not you could have got
more responsibility at work or whether
or not you could have told your partner
how you really felt is it all a guys is
not being confident a guys to excuse
yourself for constantly picking the
source of inaction
I'm very very happy for the last couple
of months for you some big wins Another
Sunday Times bestseller congrats man
mate thank you very much and the same
goes for your Camp I mean watching your
trajectory over the last few months has
been really good probably saw it before
like probably six months ago when you
went to Austin I was like this guy's
this guy's serious this guy's gonna
start moving in some big circles and
then some of the guests you've had on I
think have just bolstered your
credibility like to that next level like
uh yeah you could see it from your first
few years of effort where you were going
and uh mate it's been a pleasure to
watch you kill it as well
it's awesome to have a little community
of people that are crushing it from the
UK now really really cool and people
that are all supporting each other
whether it's the trigonometry boys or
yourself Darren's starting to step
things up you know people are moving
away to different countries places that
they know they can get more growth in
and it's really positive some every time
you win it makes me feel good which is
not necessarily something that I can say
is a common culture in the UK so I think
setting that example is probably pretty
good as well
yeah I am I hired like my first proper
employee to help me with my socials like
uh pretty much like a social digital
manager and when it was things like
YouTube I was like Chris Williamson we
need to be more like him your end cards
to your content the way things will
connect together be an interesting
Paradox that I've kind of created the
other day I call it the hater
inspiration Paradox and in essence
most of the people that probably hate on
you or hate on me if I use myself as an
example are often personal trainers or
black belts in jiu jitsu and the reason
for that is they've came to a fork in
the roads where they could have been
inspired by what I did or hate me for
what I've done and it's quite ironic
that the majority of people that will
criticize you could have all too easily
taken the same path as you to get to
success it's very weird they're not the
people that hate you the most aren't
strangers they're very similar to these
kind of like two little forks and that
I'm sure that a lot of people back in
the day would have seen what you'd done
and could have had negative negative
things to say but for me I was like what
he's doing success leaves Clues I was
like I need to step my game up even if I
could just you know follow the spearhead
even if I could just get in your your
path of least resistance behind you like
a bird flying in formation and uh yeah
it's good when we we kind of put up
strengths weaknesses of you know real
basic who in the industry is killing it
in these different social Industries and
your YouTube stuff is top level we've
already started it and you know that's
something that's good that it comes
across and the same thing for you you
know you specialize eyes I wonder how
much of the swimmer body illusion thing
comes through here with regards to
socials as well though like how many
people are moving toward a platform
which suits them me being short and
pithy the way that you do your stuff on
Instagram wouldn't really work for me
very well but the longer form more
waffily the both stuff seems to align so
yeah there's there's a lot to learn
there before we get into talking about
your new book which is on confidence
there is a food standards video that the
LA school district has just been slammed
for La school district is slammed for
posting Work video that's that calls
junk food bad is wrong and promotes New
Concept of food neutrality that claims
diet culture is based on oppression the
LA USD posted a video on Instagram
condemning negative attitudes towards
junk food and claiming diet culture is
based on oppression in the video
nutritionist Kira niembe Diop who works
with one of the world's largest snack
companies
urges people to eat food without guilt
she also asks the audience to avoid
thinking if Foods as good or bad and
instead promotes a concept of food
neutrality many took to social media to
call out the lessons in the video and
the fact that it was shared by one of
the school's districts departments what
do you think about this
well some of the things they said I've
said before but because I'm a straight
white male you know people probably
disregarded that oh it's okay for him
privileged you know all of these things
so to see it wokrified and then to have
the finger pointed uh you know I've
heard that dieting is racist it's
suppressive you know it's capitalistic
and people are getting very sidetracked
with all of this but watching the kind
of woke version of it was a bit Yeah a
bit unsettling to the very least it'd
feel like your content from 2018 was
being repurposed by the progressives
yeah and I don't understand why they
couldn't have just said hey guys there's
no such thing as a bad food just a bad
diet there's no such thing as a good
food just a good diet which I've got old
videos from 2017 saying that and to make
it all about you know oppression and
it's it's quite annoying to see
something as simple as basic diet advice
being put into a political pathway where
ultimately you know if we are going to
solve childhood obesity and improve
things in school that needs to be a
collecting effort and even if you're
you're extreme left or extreme right
surely everyone or at least the majority
of people want their family household of
young children to be brought up into the
best world eating the best food and
being the best composition for sport
Health social
activities whatever I don't understand
might be a political thing yeah there's
a couple of sentences in here that
people might not have seen if they
haven't watched the video You're judging
my food choices based on a false
standard of Health again aren't you
diet culture fat phobia and systems of
Oppression have created false
hierarchies of food and it shows up
everywhere nutritionist who's then
joined by Maya finno a black feminist
and Advocate against fat shaming who
suggests that junk food is not bad for
you we are all incorrectly taught from a
young age that our size and therefore
the food we eat are markers of our
self-worth no I don't think that anyone
says it is it's marker of your health
and your Health's worth though perhaps
the only foods that are bad for you are
foods that contain allergens poisons and
contaminants or foods that are spoiled
or otherwise inedible
I think that this seems to me to be a
way of using anything that you can get
your hands on as a political football
what can you align a particular group
with how can you rally someone behind
your cause and saying this is a pressing
insert marginalized group one and insert
marginalized group two like you know it
honestly wouldn't surprise me if somehow
they'd manage to inject sexuality into
this as well but my point being that
anybody that thinks that there are not
better ways to eat over the long term
and worse ways to eat over the long term
what job does she have being a
nutritionist also she might have a
little bit of a
um how would you say perverse incentive
given that she works for one of the
world's biggest confectionery
manufacturers like could it be that she
perhaps wants people to continue paying
her wage
maybe there's one of the most powerful
lessons I've learned from you and
there's quite a few that I'll explain in
this podcast but the inner Citadel is
Rife within this kind of you know uh
there's fat phobia which again is used
as a political tool there's body
positivity some of the objective things
she's saying you know like some people
go small with you numbers and you know
they say oh if you can't pronounce the
uh makeup of that ingredient then you
shouldn't eat it but they've never
looked at the makeup of a banana or
strawberry broken down to that level and
you know the the whole
there are I do agree with some of the
elements of Health at every size if
someone is obese there are more than one
ways we can make that person healthier
we don't have to just look at fat loss
as a single metric for improving that
person's health we can improve their
cardio uh you know cardio ability we
could get them into a team sport we
could look at their sleep we could look
at all these things but we can't just
say to people being overweight is fine
that's definitely an overcompensation
and I mean again there's lots of
examples of overcompensation here we can
even look at it there's almost a duality
here with the feminism kind of side of
things the original cause for feminism
is a fantastic cause but there is an
overcompensation that goes into the
realm of man hating and
um you know is it Miss injury or
misandry yeah Miss injury so like they
they move into those Realms of
overcompensation and it is kind of sad
to see because that in a citadel effect
is it hasn't worked for me and I'm not
surprised with the current state of diet
advice and you know some of the other
things that promoted in America but you
shouldn't go on to then a war against
people trying to give Health seeking
advice and calling them fat phobic in
the meantime I was in Rome this week
with my mum and one of the things that I
noticed while I was there was the
difference in portion sizes
frankly I was still hungry after I
finished some meals but I was satisfied
now that's because I'm used to my
satiated level is starter main side and
big dessert and I was getting an all
right sized Mane but it wasn't that big
and then maybe some gelato on the way
past and I was still hungry but I was
thinking to myself as I looked around
the center of Rome which is a
Cosmopolitan City with people of all
backgrounds and ethnicities and probably
a big chunk of people in different
classes as well
the difference in BMI between that City
and a lot of the ones in America is
pretty Stark and that I think can
probably almost exclusively be laid at
the feet of portion sizes
yeah Joe I was in Italy a few months ago
and it's so funny the Italian culture I
got on like a an EasyJet flight the 7am
EasyJet flight swinging traveling around
Europe seems so appealing and so you do
the maths off you pay for it okay that
needs to be at the airport for five [ __ ]
that means I've got to get up at four
with a four in it anytime waking up with
a fork so I was pretty grumpy on my way
there and the way that Italians don't
queue or they have a very different way
of queuing to us so I'm tired I'm at the
airport and people are just walking into
the front and I'm like messaging manager
Luke I'm like man Italian's rude he's
like that's what they're like and I was
like oh god I've got to get used to this
and uh the food is incredible in Italy
like it's incredible but it is crazy you
go to like the Mediterranean or
something like that and
they say people are Slimmer they're in
better shape they seem to be drinking
all the time as well I'm there like how
do you guys do this like there's a new
system I want to sell is it having a
cigarette with a bit of coffee at
breakfast but then is it having wine
with every meal maybe we're missing out
on something that they we need to take
over to America and so I think it's just
make the potion sizes smaller man
honestly make the portion sizes smaller
seems to be the biggest difference I
could find but yeah
to run that off I think that
any opportunity for people to use
intersectionality and or oppression as
the vehicle with which to uh it latches
itself onto something that is a common
talking point like Diet fat phobia body
image body shaming uh yeah it's it's
pretty dangerous because you're talking
about things that impact People's Health
generally genuinely impact People's
Health this isn't just a fashion choice
this isn't about whether guys should be
allowed to paint their nails or
something like this is a one of the
fundamental elements that's going to
contribute to your health long term
moving on to confidence what do you
think
given all of the research that you did
for your book what do you think that
most people misbelieve about confidence
uh it's interesting that there is there
are several kind of lines of thought and
I'll say that half of what I wrote In
the book I knew before half I didn't and
you know John I'm still not solid the
whole book doesn't say this is exactly
what it is I go through many theories
where I see confidence on loads of
spectrums you know confidence and
anxiety confidence predicting the
outcome of success anxiety predicting
the outcome of failure then we could
look at confidence alongside failure is
confidence being okay with failure or is
confident something tied to winning
um one of my favorite elements that I'll
credit you for was when we were in
Austin together I was thinking a few
beers you told me about the zygonic
effect
and you started telling me about how you
can open and close Loops in your lives
and if you don't do anything
it's going to take on mental drain on
you and something that now that's
something you can leave with someone
they can never forget so I say to people
is confidence [ __ ] in some respects
that the majority of people use it as a
reason to pick a path of inaction so you
hit a fork in the road you can either
take action or take an action if you go
through life always taking the path of
inaction always opening these Loops
wondering whether or not the girl on the
tube was single whether or not your boss
would have given you a pay rise whether
or not you could have got more
responsibility at work or whether or not
you could have told your partner how you
really felt
is it all the guys is not being
confident of guys to excuse yourself for
constantly picking the source of
inaction and if we can call [ __ ] on
this concept of low confidence can we
start looking things more pragmatically
as an ability to close loops and not
even for confidence as part of that to
the side for anxiety mental mental drain
insomnia you know everyone's had it
probably where you've had a big night
out it's the easiest way to explain it
and you wake up and straight away you
think you've lost your phone
and you know you haven't lost your phone
you know you were texting or firing
flares when you got in you up babe or
whatever it was but you have to close
the loop by getting up and holding the
phone and going it's here and so one of
the first things that I kind of learned
and I speak about in the book and the
talk is are we using low confidence as
an excuse to get away with not picking a
path of action continually in life and
that really is a really hard point for
people to think about because once you
planted that seed in my mind it couldn't
go away and that was kind of liberating
and then I was quite excited to plant
that seed into everyone else's mind
afterwards it's a dangerous thing to
know to think about the fact that maybe
I use I'm not very confident as an
excuse to not put myself into situations
where I can potentially face failure
because by inoculating myself from
making action in the real world I ensure
that failure never comes up against Me
by never actually stepping Under The
Arena floor and I think that that that's
a
that's a concern for a lot of people man
it
the open Loops thing I'd never thought
about applying it to confidence and to
the uh the fact that people cause
inaction to occur in their life and
you're right the number of times that
you think I wonder what if how many
what-ifs are you going to have what if
I'd spoken to the girl on the Metro what
if I decided to ask my boss for a pay
rise what if I decided to move to
another country what if I'd left that
toxic relationship I didn't want to what
if I stepped in and told my dad or my
mum that their health habits were
terrible and they shouldn't listen to
that La School District lady all of
these different things are continuing to
open something in the back of your mind
and even if you're not consciously
keeping track of them I do believe that
the subconscious is I do believe that
every time that you decide to lean out
as opposed to lean in
you are making yourself into the sort of
person who is going to continue to lean
out in future when difficulty arises
when you are faced with an opportunity
or a challenge that you need to try and
overcome okay every single decision that
you make now
is going to engender a type of person
that will make that same kind of
decision in future so it's not just
about what are you doing now how much do
you want to speak to that girl it's do
you want to be the sort of person in
five years time that would speak to the
girl or not
it's an objectively known as well in
Psychology that when you uh question
people on their deathbed especially old
people and you ask them about their life
people regret the things they didn't do
not the things they did do that didn't
work out and we need to instill and kind
of haunt people a little bit to fully
appreciate that when you are 50 years
older than you are now if you're lucky
you are going to regret all of these
open Loops these what ifs we're going to
regret them and they're all going to
cause them a lot of mental Carnage in
your mind and there's something so
beautiful about getting closure on
something and realizing it wasn't that
bad and another thing I'm sure you've
read quite a bit of Tim ferriss's work
as well and one of his most famous
uh kind of tasks was about asking for a
10 discount on a coffee
and I just wanted to insert that in the
book I just wanted to take that
beautiful idea of asking 10 and put it
in but what I realized is by putting it
in the book I opened my own Loop and
then I had to go do the task that I
never wanted to do I just wanted to put
it in there and I thought no one will
know and I thought oh no this is going
to haunt me I'm not even going to be
able to release the book and I remind
people that asking for 10 off a coffee
isn't to get the 10 off it's to look
like a complete imbecile a buffoon is to
embarrass yourself it's to complete
completely disintegrate any comfort that
you have but it's only past that point
you can appreciate how valuable it was
putting yourself out there and how it
wasn't that scary and when you can
accrue enough of these little victories
whether it's the number asking someone a
single even if that girl says no thanks
I've got a boyfriend even if she's lying
there is a Euphoria after not because of
the outcome because of the the action
that you perceived so scarily big that
you do it and you realize it wasn't that
bad at all did you come across when you
were looking at the ask for 10 of coffee
did you come across rejection therapy
and their hundred days of rejection
program
no tell me more okay so
rejectiontherapy.com and there is a
hundred days of rejection principle here
and you're supposed to do this one per
day for 100 days and it's basically the
same as what you're talking about right
it's exposure therapy for people that
don't like to do awkward things uh
borrow a hundred dollars from a stranger
request a burger refill ask for an
Olympic symbol donut deliver pizza for
Domino's have a tour in a grocery store
Warehouse play soccer in someone else's
backyard uh speak over Costco's intercom
get and get number one spot in Best
Buy's Thanksgiving line send stuff to
Santa Claus Santa Claus through FedEx
listen to a happy birthday song when
it's not your birthday learn sales from
the number two car salesman in the
country like these are all different
things that you can do there's a tedx
talk of the same uh the same name that
people can go and have a look at but
lots of people have done it and I think
it is it's just exposure therapy about
learning how unscary and undestructive
receiving a no is a lot of people I
think have this tantamount to complete
Annihilation fear that if they go up to
someone and they don't get the response
that they're expecting that
I don't know just on the other side of
that is obliteration
they think it's pirick which is another
thing you I think you might mention
parent victories is from your email that
you sent out before is this Victory
tantamount to defeat in many cases no
and you know what I I've kind of tripped
up into this because through being poor
so when I was a student I had no money I
would you know would take anything for
work I worked in a pub on a on a like a
pretty much like a caravan site when I
was 16 when it was my 18th birthday the
guy who hired me was like how would you
ask 18 he's like you kidding me you've
been working in this Pub for two years
he's like I thought you were 18 before
so I used to work up there we used to
have like you know builders in all the
time
whatever it was and then uh I got
offered a job working in shopping
centers stopping people to to sell to
them so this is 10 15 years ago do you
remember when Blockbuster started facing
its demise love film came out where you
get posted your DVDs so I worked as a
contractor for love film and for every
person I stopped and signed up to a
membership I got seven pounds would you
get you two coffees from Costa nowadays
so I used to do that in shopping centers
so the majority of things I experienced
for knows then I got a job in
door-to-door sales working for Npower in
Gloucester knocking on doors trying to
convert people from the big giant
British gas over to Npower in some cases
I could save people four pounds a month
and then I had to be like hey look 40 50
pounds a year that's a good saving so I
got rejected so much that I didn't
realize how brilliant that was for me
you know having things doors shut in
your face people telling you to [ __ ] off
people getting angry that you're there
trying to save the money or whatever and
I kind of went through that rejection
therapy is part of what work and it's
weird because at the time I was like I
didn't enjoy it but looking back now
it's one thing I'm most grateful for
how much did that that crossover into
other areas of rejection fear and
confidence though because I know that
you've spoken about how you drink or
drank a lot before going on first dates
because of anxiety about going up and
speaking to a girl for the first time
even one that you've organized to go on
a date with or if you were given the
choice between going and giving a
presentation in front of a thousand
people unprepared or asking for a girl's
number in a bar you would happily go and
give the presentation so it does seem
like there's different buckets or
domains that confidence doesn't
necessarily always cross over into a
hundred percent and again the public
speaking thing for some reason it
relaxes me do you know what's really
weird and this is going to sound like
such a narcissistic thing the bigger the
crowd the more I can relax because the
less I can actually appreciate how many
people are in the room so if there's
20 I don't know 25 30 people I can
actually lock eyes and you know
actually appreciate they're there when
you get past a thousand people it's
beautiful because you can't lock into
anyone that's there but I think the
rejection thing you're completely right
and I speak about this in the talk of
saying that in essence I'm an insecurity
machine because I became a PT through
working on my own Securities I wanted to
be less insecure and feel less inferior
to other men so then I did that and then
when I became PT it was you know
inadequacies and inferiorities that
didn't really make prospecting a good
thing because someone might not be able
to afford PT they might not want PT they
might be doing another plan but it's
very difficult to not take that
personally especially when you do
appreciate I never really appreciated
love film and I really appreciated
Npower but I appreciated myself as a
trainer I was like I work hard I'm good
I'm worth the money so when I got
rejected there I was like oh that kind
of hurts so then I'm through being
insecure there that's what led me down
the path of making social media content
so I made content so people would
organically come to me they were a warm
lead it would make the whole idea of
prospecting or conversion easier but
then I became insecure about my content
being right so now our fear of judgment
and fear of you know all of this then I
started going out and searching and
educating myself on evidence-based
courses in essence a lot of the success
I've had in my life has come through
work and on my insecurities which then I
only really clocked that this is one of
the main lessons of Jordan Peterson
where if you're on an existential crisis
you're not sure what to do with your
life take stock of your insecurities and
work on them and I was like I look back
and I'm like wow I didn't even know that
and I was doing it
there are a lot of places that people
can look I mean Peterson said this on
the second episode that I did with him
earlier this year
if you don't think that you have
anything that you need to work on in
your life look inward you know you're
not telling the truth sufficiently you
are not living up to your highest ideals
you're making promises to yourself and
other people that you're not keeping
just this endless list of inadequacies
that small things you know the tiny
little things I promise that I would
wash up tonight to myself I promised I
would wash the dish and the glass that I
had dinner in and I didn't do it well
that's a thing that's a thing that you
can work on
a lot of people will have probably
thought when it comes to confidence
especially looking at you
what's the chicken and egg scenario here
does confidence come first or does
competence come first can you fake it
until you make it what do you thought
sir so I don't like the fake it to make
it thing I think it's
kind of a bit of a
check out the conversation that's a
chicken and egg thing itself but you're
completely right what I don't like and
I'll bring this into a context that
you'll be familiar with is
when people see success straight away
they like to connect their own dots it's
like a heuristic where suddenly they're
like boom boom okay cool and some of the
ways that I don't like they do is they
go oh you know Chris Williamson he's a
confident guy he's got a podcast and
you're like okay was he confident then
he started a podcast or do you start a
podcast that built his confidence you
know the fact that you can jump into a a
podcast for three hours without show
notes is that competence or confidence
exactly like you said then they'll
sprinkle that with some ideology that's
right at the moment they'll guys a
straight white male as well you know I
got everything they wanted in school we
got picked for sports teams all of these
things which makes it a lot more of a
complex debate but with me I think that
it's only in retrospect that people now
go eyes he's confident I'm like part of
me wants to say [ __ ] you I was
frightened at the beginning I was
petrified I was you know scared alone I
was at you know I was a PT on my own
even though it doesn't seem like a scary
kind of job it was I left the corporate
world I moved back in my parents I could
have all too easily ended up skin broken
going back to door-to-door sales so you
know even that industry is quite siled
off because although you have banned
with other pts your competitors you're
not colleagues you're in there fighting
for the same thing
and then it's just through consistent
being okay with failing turning up and
you know I'm coming up to 10 years now
if you if you've got anyone to do
anything for 10 years that appear
[ __ ] confident you know not some my
mate cam is a carpenter I watch them do
stuff I'm like mate you're a wizard and
he was like me I've been doing this
since I was 15 and I'm like okay that
makes sense so it does kind of annoy me
that people look at 10 years hard work
and they can almost use this elixir of
confidence as a reason to not fully
appreciate what you've done I mean what
episode of podcasts will this be
530 540.
so when you look at that times the hours
sometimes I I'm not saying [ __ ] you to
the people I'm saying [ __ ] you to their
heuristics their their mental
tendency to just take the reality and
squish it and pull it apart to make it
seem like it's trivial because that
completely undermines the cheat code to
success what people need to be doing is
to stop that that tendency to just make
a snapshot decision of how it happened
and look into it if someone's going
[ __ ] hell 500 podcasts how many hours
is that oh two hours a [ __ ] podcast a
thousand hours this guy's you know on
his way to Mastery not to mention
everything else you've done outside of
it so yeah the competency thing is is
big and one of my favorite kind of
lessons is about saying to people stop
avoiding failure because there is a
massive utility to failing failing is
brilliant because it brings you closer
to competency it also shows you the path
to not do things so even if we go back
to my door-to-door sales if I was too
cheeky to crass too provocative to
facetious to you know nonchalant it
didn't work so and again my YouTube
strategy at the moment is to put out 100
videos and take stock of what works and
what doesn't ultimately the algorithm
wants people to watch my videos If a
video doesn't do well it's on me double
down on what does work if I didn't or I
was so fearful of putting out a video
that underperformed I didn't put it out
I wouldn't be able to take that utility
of it not performing so you know if
people don't look at failure that way
you know having a go just go oh no gross
that was a horrible chat although that
is devastating to your ego and your
confidence and your morale that could be
a lesson in which you can take upon
yourself to then improve and if people
don't look at failure as having this
incredible utility they're going to
really struggle to ever develop their
competence and I say to people if you
become competent at something two years
time someone's going to say to you
you're confident it's not it's almost
like a byproduct of seeking competency
that we get this magical superpower of
being confident it seems like your
expectations around what you can do and
the challenges that the world is going
to put up against you are one of the
fundamental elements that this is the
first time that you do a live or a
podcast or write a sub stack or pitch to
someone on the front door of their house
on a cold December evening or something
you don't know what your capacities are
and you don't know the challenges that
you're up against and then even after
you do know what your capacities are
sometimes the challenge can be so much
further beyond anything that you've done
before that you think oh God like this
is really really scary to me
but
if you can get yourself into the mindset
that on the edge of your zone of
development is exactly where you're
going to find out just how good you are
and if if you're not that good then
fantastic because it's going to give you
feedback I think I've heard you say that
um winning can cause you to become weak
too much winning can cause weakness and
I mean anyone that's been through a
difficult breakup like not one of the
ones that completely destroyed your life
but one way you felt a little bit bitter
and resentful afterward your gym
discipline your diet discipline your
personal development at least for me and
a lot of my friends for the next three
to six months was unbelievable turbo
powered by that well why you've just
come out the back of a failure you've
come out the back of something that
shouldn't have happened or you get
scorned or someone takes the piss out of
you or a person that you respected
rebuts your efforts or something like
that
that is motivation for a lot of people
as well and there definitely is a case
of comfortable complacency that comes
along with too many wins or at least too
many wins that are within a domain that
you were never going to be challenged if
you keep on winning and you're always
beating new records and always pushing
yourself I'm not sure that that would
cause you to uh lose the edge but
certainly the opportunity to use failure
as fuel is a pretty big blessing for
people
I think this is why I love Jiu Jitsu so
much because I had a period 2020 came
out the pandemic I trained a bit during
the pandemic uh you know I did some
sneaky privates with the local black
belts and I went to compete and I was
like this is my opportunity to shine and
I even this is the only time I've truly
been overconfident with Jiu Jitsu this
is exactly the humbling I needed and I
said to my housemates I'll be pretty
annoyed if I don't get gold and I lost
all my matches like embarrassingly so my
first match I tried too hard and I
gassed out and the most horrible feeling
was knowing I'd lost I'm tying my belt
three minutes into the match and I was
like I'm done and I the only time I'd
competed and said I don't want to be
here and he kind of finished me and my
whole team were there in the corner and
I couldn't look at them they're like
well done I'm like don't say Well done
to me I didn't deserve it then the next
match my mates were like relax relax
you'll be fine this guy just took my
back and choked me out and they were
like he didn't even try they weren't
even they won't even try and Coach me
they were like why didn't you just try
it I was like my head is gone and the
next day it was probably the only day
that I felt like depressed about
something in years and nothing to do
with business work whatever
and then there was that little switch in
my mind where I just started taking
things so much more seriously I started
doing privates with people I started
studying I started looking into
positions a bit more and like the next
six months I was a monster at training I
was like I didn't matter who you were I
was like I need to start scalping the
higher belts whatever it was and then
when I get through a period of being
really comfortable with my training I
sit there and I go [ __ ] I'm gonna have
to compete again and when I compete I
can't I hate losing but I welcome it If
I Lose I'm gonna get that kind of Beast
trainee person back who eats more
vegetables hits their protein goes to
sleep earlier says no to the beers and
the last time I competed it was a really
weird emotion I wanted to win with
everything I had but I kind of wanted to
get beaten as well
and I won on my matches it's the hardest
I've ever worked in com and at the end
of it I couldn't believe how hard I'd
worked for someone who kind of wanted to
get beaten and it was beautiful it was
euphoric it was amazing and then I came
to the conclusion I've got to competeer
a bigger tournament now and obviously
Jiu Jitsu isn't my life I don't get paid
to do Jiu Jitsu I teach a class for free
on a Friday like whatever it is
that to instill the values and the the
lessons I needed to take into everything
else is is such a beautiful thing I
think that's why so many people love Jiu
Jitsu because
even Rogan Lex Friedman Jocko willink
all these people if they ever feel like
they're winning too much in their life
they can put themselves in a room where
they get humbled and they realize
they're not that great and yeah your
podcast might be doing well yeah you
might have made 100 million last year
yeah you might have got this big deal
but come to this room and get get truly
scorned get beaten get scalped get
humiliated in some respects and it's
such a beautiful feeling because if you
remain in this Echo chambered room of
winning and you're the best or the
greatest which is all too easy with
success
you have too many yes men and I think
they can really diminish
your full potential it's always good
once in a while to put yourself in that
room and be terrified when I trained in
Austin I I relish the facts I was
probably if you put everyone in
competency order I was in the bottom of
three and the other two guys that were
in that bottom three with me I was like
we're in it we're in this together guys
heritable is confidence did you look at
that yes so heritability incompetence is
an interesting one I actually found an
interesting study about adopted children
and so me myself being adopted I was
like is there am I some of my
personality traits you know in my genes
and they were saying that adoptive kids
resemble the traits of their parents up
until their young teenage years and then
they start moving into more of their
genetic sequence and code
then I started getting into this debate
of gender and confidence but I stayed
clear of some of the debates because I
was like are men genuinely more
competent are they more disillusioned
are they more you know programmed
through Evolution to be more competitive
things and I was like you know what I
probably don't know enough about gender
to delve into this but what I kind of
came to the conclusion was
if you want to be a woman that's taller
than a man you've got it up against you
if you want to be a woman who's stronger
than a man okay things are more in your
control you could be you know start
working towards a higher Echelon that's
something that you can rework towards
but I was like if you want to be more
confident than the majority of people
that's something you can actually do and
I could point at anyone no matter what
disadvantages they had from a genetic
standpoint uh upbringing standpoint a
trauma standpoint give me that person
for a year and get them to do enough
practice you can make something
incredibly confident whereas you can't
make people taller you can't make them
you know more symmetrical in the face
you can't give them whatever it is that
people say you like when you're looking
at Social content and I think there's a
beauty to even if you've got it against
you from a hereditary standpoint or a
genetic standpoint you can do the
[ __ ] work and get over it if you want
to play in the NBA and you're five foot
two you know that's something where I'm
like oh maybe maybe you need a better
goal
it's interesting to think
how low the bar is set
for most people this is one of the
things that I think the black pill
insult sort of discussion really gets
wrong when it comes to men that aren't
in the top 20 of men aren't being looked
at by almost any women and blah blah
blah
do you realize how little almost every
guy works on himself
almost when you step outside of the
world of Internet personalities and look
at the normal humans on the street
almost no one is doing pretty much
anything to develop themselves and make
themselves better the people that are
listening to this podcast simply by
being interested in longer form
conversations about personal development
are in the top probably percentile if
not maybe five percent globally right
all of the grandmothers that don't know
what podcasts exist all of the okay and
then we'll reduce it down to men only
and all of the grandfathers that don't
know it that it exists and all of the
people that are too young and all of the
people that are too busy working and all
of the people that don't have an
interest or an intellectual Pursuit all
of it all the way down then to the point
when all of the people that can't be
bothered that don't have the motivation
to do it that don't feel like it's going
to be worth their time that they're too
busy thinking about other things that
haven't got the inclination to do it the
bar is set so low because the selection
effect is unbelievably low as well and I
think that if more people understood
that the competition is
minute and all of the challenges that
people come up against the boredom the
repetition the loss of Faith the fear of
rejection everybody else faces that as
well so you have to presume that if
you're facing it and you just get an
inch past it
you have selected yourself out from what
everybody feels into what only a tiny
tiny sliver of what is already a tiny
subsection of everybody feels to become
an extraordinary individual to me
doesn't seem like a particularly
difficult Pursuit it just requires a
little bit of movement and this is
something that going through your book I
kind of realized which is the Matthew
principle are you familiar with this
okay it'll be in my next book I'm sure
it will uh in the Bible they talk about
it's in it's in Matthew which is why
it's called the Matthew principle and
they say um from those who have
everything more will be given from those
who have nothing more will be taken and
it describes well we call it what you
want the perito principle or power laws
right these are ways that people who are
winning a crew more wins and wins a crew
to the people that already have them
people that are losing a crew more
losses and losses continue to push down
and it seems to me that confidence works
like this as well that
people who have even a tiny amount
they've decided to take that first step
that inertia that they've got past and
then they get a little bit of positive
feedback from the world so they have a
bit of self-belief and then they decide
to go a little bit further and again a
bit more self-belief that is how you
look at a a Rogan or a Dave Chappelle or
uh
Adele Beckham Jr or whoever you hold in
high esteem as somebody that's
incredibly confident they have drilled
this Matthew principle where confidence
breeds competence breeds confidence
breeds competence and after a while they
look superhuman you know I I I I can't
believe the capability that this person
has and then especially perhaps Rogan
might be a good example for this where
you have someone that has crossed that
confidence into multiple domains so it's
somebody that's not just prepared to do
the podcasting but then the live shows
but then the Jiu Jitsu but then the
commentary but then all that stuff right
Douglas Murray is a not only a speaker
but he's a writer but he does the
journalism thing like someone that has
gone through all of these you think it
that person is so unbelievably
willing to do things to the point where
I can't recognize them as as someone
that is from the same species as me and
then you look at the people at the
bottom and it's brutal because if you
don't have the confidence to develop
competence you are going to reinforce
that same cycle and I think that this
Matthew principle from those who have
everything more will be given from those
who have nothing more will be taken just
continues to diverge people and this
isn't some CIS heteronormative
patriarchal superstructure right this is
simply the reinforcement mechanism
Peterson spoke about this on the podcast
he said almost all of the rivers uh
almost all of the water in rivers are
held by only the biggest ones almost all
of the mass that's held by star are only
held in the biggest ones like this is
the way that things work in the world
this isn't due to some cultural artifact
this is simply due to the fact that
people who do things and objects that
have capability
continue to do it more and more and more
someone said to me oh it's impressive
you wrote a book and I said no and I
went in and I said I said [ __ ] you I was
like no I was like you've annoyed me
with the way you've thought about this
and I said to them I sit you down on a
Monday uh I give you a laptop they give
you unlimited coffee I give you the
internet and I put a pistol to the back
of your head and I say here's your topic
I want you to research for 15 minutes
right for 15 minutes we're going to meet
at the same time every day we're going
to do this for 30 minutes every day
there's going to be a gun in the back of
your head every day if you don't do it
I'll shoot you and in a year's time
we're going to assimilate all your work
and we're going to look to see whether
or not you've put something together
worth 10 pounds
cool suddenly you realize it's not
impressive to write a book it's not
impressive to write a good book all it
takes is work and consistency the
hardest barrier to write in a good book
is the belief that you can do it the
belief that you can turn up every day
and put this together then the belief
that you're willing to do the work and
preparation required to sell it promote
it go to the book signings whatever it
is
it's not an impressive feat to write a
book it's an impressive feat to believe
you can do all of it together
and it's interesting what you say about
Joe I've really been thinking about this
whole status and Men thing and it is a
really really interesting thing and
there are some things that men can't do
and again something I'm not sure if I'm
opposed disgusted offended or or what
about it by the six sixes get out of
this
amen
so women over the years have whether or
not it's made up by women or this was
made up by men I'm not sure but it says
women want the six sixes over six foot
over six figure salary over 600 brake
horsepower car
six months since next girlfriend
six pack
and six inches below the waist
now the majority of women
not probably publicly on camera are
looking for that and the statistics on
dating apps 80 of women want a woman
over a man over six foot which is 15 of
the population
so there are unrealistic expectations
from women especially when it comes to
dating I didn't even know on hinge you
can actually uh take off uh the height
requirements so they even get blind
swiped a friend of mine I won't name him
uh he had to change his ethnicity
because he was getting nice no swipes so
to the point that
you know I was saying to mate your
account is broken or even Shadow banned
or whatever it was and he had to lie
about his ethnicity to White just to get
matches what was his original one
well he's from Morocco right so I'm not
sure what what he put in is that he's
Arab I feel like it might be
maybe maybe something like that but for
him to lie about his ethnicity and he
definitely lied about his height
are you shortly and I was like wow we're
trying to jump through all of these
hoops but if we were to look as a
statistic of how many men are actually
within the six sixes you're talking a
fraction of a percentage and if the
majority of women are after that not
only is that fact but I've often thought
about how could I help men with the
things that are obtainable and I would
love to put together a program where you
can mix
a good mindset an entrepreneurial brain
and a martial art and you know the
competency con confidence Thing Once you
have mastered or got your blue belt in
you know martial arts or you've got to
the gym and you've sorted yourself out
once you can get someone to deadlift
their body weight do a chin up strangle
out someone at the same belt level you
know run a 5k without having a heart
attack
have an online business where they put
their laptop out for a few hours at
night and they can create money or
whatever suddenly not only do you create
a lifestyle that's congruent to
happiness in a lot of people not only to
improve their self-worth their
competency in the gym whatever it is you
start to build their status from the
inside up and there are so many tools
like you say that are just uncomfortable
for people people that want to sell a
product I'm going to put themselves out
there people that want to you know lift
in the gym don't want to be embarrassed
or to get in the front of someone else
people that go to martial arts are
worried about sucking for the first two
years although that is the only way you
can get better and I do often think that
you know if a man out there wanted the
six sixes he's looking at the wrong
things because I don't even think that
the those six elements are
backed up by literature the height thing
especially I believe you said it was
it's not a predictor and a success in a
relationship no so there's a issue that
we have here that the
desired preferences from both men and
women on the front end are not the
things that predict relationship
happiness long term but there is an
argument to be made that those are the
things that get you past the front door
however if you get past the front door
regularly and the relationships aren't
effective you go well what's the point
of of doing this in the first place this
is just like transactional sex I'm just
masturbating with someone else's body
here
um so I heard that
um all right so talk to me about it
seems like anxiety in this sort of fear
of failure is one of the key elements of
confidence or a lack of it what did you
discover as the relationship between
confidence and anxiety
so we need to have it ties into
expectations as well similar to what you
said because if we see anxieties
predicting an outcome of failure that is
also governed by a lot of mental biases
we have we have loss aversion negativity
bias we've got all of these kind of
things pretty much you know like uh when
you go to I've just thought of this as
analogy again and you roll the ball and
it always is tilted to one way so it
usually Curves in the direction of the
weighted ball if you had pessimism on
the left and optimism on the right the
way the human brain works is if you roll
it down the middle it's going to curve
off towards the pessimism side so we
have that so this tendency to predict
things as a negative outcome is going to
happen so how is it that we predict an
outcome of success how is it we can
bolster our expectations
it's not a simple exercise but we do
need to go into things you know being
more
optimistic about it and if if we're
really crippled by this fear of anxiety
or whatever can we redefine the metrics
for Success so let's say you are a
single man you feel like you're a low
status you feel like you're petrified
can you just say hello to someone can
you compliment them on what they're
wearing can you ask them what they do
not invasive not creepy be chivalrous
hold a door open someone hey
uh you know my name is James uh I'm the
senior around here before do you study
here are you you know is this your local
coffee shop you know I usually say hello
whatever there's something within
people's capability that they have the
confidence to do whether it's
prospecting or talking someone for their
business if you set the bars too far
it's always going to be very daunting
and again we can always relate this back
to Fitness
you can you never as a trainer would get
someone into the gym and get them to do
something they can't do that's going to
diminish their confidence their ego the
self-esteem whatever it's all about
finding what they can do and working
with them to decide what's the next
logical step and that's why we have
little 2.5 kilogram disks you know
that's why we have these things so if
people can just snap out this mentality
of being pessimistic expecting things to
go badly if I get someone to squat 50
kilograms I'm now instilled into them
that they're strong enough to do it you
can then work along with them and say
look I think 55 is within your reach if
you can do 50 for five you can do 52.5
[ __ ] three whatever it is and we need
to install Progressive overload into
people we would never Chuck 40 kilograms
on someone's back squat and expect them
to do it so when people do take stock of
this appreciation that they're going to
predict a negative outcome okay why is
that we set in the metrics for Success
too high can we break this down to okay
Jiu Jitsu scares the [ __ ] out of you
could you go to a local gym and say
hello could you watch 10 minutes of a
class okay dating scares the [ __ ] out of
you could you talk to a stranger you
know okay business goes the [ __ ] out of
you okay could you call call one person
a day to pitch for business whatever it
is
and yeah in essence the anxiety is
sometimes caused by having a lack of
evidence that you're good at it but you
can't accrue evidence without action
so it has to be almost action first
create evidence that you're competent
diminish anxiety over time but it is
such a complex nuanced debate that's
case-specific in essence we kind of just
need to get people and and wrap them up
and say you need to take action you're
not going to know anything about
yourself your capabilities until you
start doing it and it's so much about
getting moving and correcting the course
on the way have you ever noticed that
like you write brilliant email marketing
emails
sometimes you just gotta start writing
and then you can always delete the first
third and then you have a beautiful
brilliant email the worst thing is being
sat there with nothing on your screen
being crippled by this notion that you
don't know what you're going to do a lot
of the time I'll just start typing
getting a flow get realized that this
isn't even the topic I want to write
about go back delete the first part and
I'm suddenly there action proceeds
motivation action precedes competence
action proceeds you know confidence all
of these things and it's about taking
the step first and correcting it on the
way I think that's right I think that
people being stuck in in action spinning
the wheels with the anxiety costs or the
open Loops from the zygonic effect just
playing rampant in their mind another
thing to consider as well is that
failure under conditions of optimism is
very different to failure under
conditions of pessimism because failure
under pessimism confirms your fears
failure under optimism feels like an
aberration and this is something
that I've been thinking about a little
bit that having a single vehicle for
developing your confidence seems like a
good idea now we mentioned earlier on
that confidence in one area doesn't
necessarily always cross over just
because you're great at rugby doesn't
mean that you're going to be able to
speak to girls in a bar but I do think
that having a primary vehicle that you
build that confidence competence
feedback loop is a really good idea and
the reason for it is you become ever
more attuned to how your performance
within that particular domain is going
and I think that maybe for you it's
Brazilian Jiu Jitsu and writing perhaps
or Brazilian Jiu Jitsu and social media
or something like that certainly for me
looking and I reflected a lot reading
the book on sort of my journey from
pretty unconfident person to now at
least within certain domains feeling
fine to go on Rogan or to speak to
George you're very very [ __ ] composed
on that I messaged you I was like how's
he doing this how's he doing this
because any person that's got any
digital Persona or presence always
imagines what it'd be like to get a
message from Morgan and you got it you
went on and it was like it was your
third episode it was like you're one of
his mates and Larry and I messaged you I
was like [ __ ] you know how are you doing
this I want to know how many ice baths
have you been having yeah maybe that
contributed well it's interesting with
that like
people brought that up about you know
the Rogan thing it's a big deal but
it would have been a bigger deal for me
to go through this entire journey of
making 500 podcasts and speaking to all
of these people and then to get a
message and and feel like it was a shock
it's like no this is what you were
working towards this is what you meant
to happen like yeah maybe you've jumped
ahead a few moves that you were
pleasantly surprised by but this is
literally the the goal of what you you
didn't mean for this to not happen
therefore congratulations but yeah the
journey in having a single Pursuit that
you can focus on look this is my vehicle
for me developing my confidence and I
think that
it's so interesting reflecting on the
person that I was maybe four or five
years ago especially starting the show
or the way that I would have framed
things because it was very very
anxious-centric it was very much loss
aversion I would be playing not to lose
rather than to win that would have been
my Approach I would have always been
trying to take a very easy no failure
potential route that would have been how
I would have gone about stuff and now if
I have a bad episode on the show one
that I consider to be bad when my
performance isn't quite right rather
than saying this is some moral judgment
on my worth as a person this is because
I am useless bad inconsistent
undisciplined whatever whatever I can
just look at it as what it is I'm a lot
more detached from my performance and my
self-worth because I can say well look
what's the reason for why you performed
the way you performed maybe you were
under slapped maybe you hadn't hydrated
enough maybe you were too hungry maybe
you hadn't prepared enough for the guest
perhaps the guest was having a bad day
maybe it's not your fault maybe it's
them that what else can you do and
that's what I mean when failure under
conditions of pessimism versus failure
in the conditions of optimism are very
very different experiences it's that
John Kavanaugh thing you win or you
learn and whereas in Reverse it's either
I don't know you fail and your
preconceived ideas about what you were
going to do are confirmed or you're
surprised like that's the alternative
right that's pessimism versus optimism
yeah and it's interesting I joke there
about ice baths so I'm not I'm not a fan
of ice baths it doesn't mean I don't
rate what they do for people I just
don't like cold water and I think there
is with confidence as well
if you can do things that
really disturb you like not not from
trauma but like competing for me I hate
it because I put so much pressure on
myself to to win and I also just put so
much pressure on myself I'm like this is
my identity this I love this what I want
to do that
it's frightening it's terrifying and
especially when you can get injured so
in training people won't try and injure
you in competition it's about making
your opponent submit if a leg breaks if
a knee pops anything it's kind of fair
game you put yourself in the competition
bracket you don't know anything about
your opponent you don't know what
they're like I joke and I go baby's been
to jail maybe you know whatever it is
I saw like a spiral fracture and
someone's humorous from someone not
tapping so [ __ ] can get pretty gnarly
but by putting myself in there and when
I'm competing I said I hate competing I
hate it when I'm sitting there on the
map my feet are sliding around in sweat
inside my flip-flops I'm stood there and
for the moment before I step on I go why
am I here why have I ruined my weekend
by doing this but the second is all over
suddenly everything else isn't so bad
suddenly the podcast the FaceTime the
talking on stage whatever and I think
that's why a lot of people get you know
such benefit advice paths because when
they sat there their minds saying stay
their body's saying what are you doing
we're gonna die and if you can if you
can harness the monster of that
discomfort suddenly get a nice bath and
go oh I'm single I'm lonely that's a
pain point I'd like to address it
there's a loop here I could close I'm
gonna take my headphones out hey look
never seen you in the Starbucks before
uh you know I think a really pretty if
you haven't got a boyfriend here's my
number if you do have a boyfriend or you
want to lie to me that's completely fine
day you know I mean suddenly if someone
was to go ice bath for five minutes or
ask the guy oh ask 10 birds out you know
ask 10 of them so that's why you need to
do it man I think and this is something
I realized living with Zach because
we've got a nice bath now at the back of
the house which you'll be forced into
when you come back to Austin and for me
I find it it's difficult but it's not
that hard 40 degree water for three five
minutes we've worked ourselves up to now
and it's just not that hard for me so
although it's I can almost Kid myself
into convincing me that I've done
something hard because for zaka is Zach
was getting in and out talking to
himself he'd been for 20 seconds he'd
get out call himself a [ __ ] get back in
get back out for 10 seconds get back in
and he'd be shouting at himself I've
seen I've watched that boy get in and
out of cold tubs
like in reps he's done reps of cold
stubs not sets and
it's easy to kid yourself that the thing
that you're doing is difficult a lot of
the time I think that's people playing
within their own inner Citadel perhaps
or just like their zone of competence
and another thing that I was considering
as well is how rarely
driven people celebrate their wins
you very very quickly looking past
whatever it is that you've just done
peering over its shoulder
even as it's only just finished
to then think about what's next and this
is a real delicate balance I think that
people need
to be able to be grateful thankful
and and celebrity of their own victories
whilst not letting themselves lose that
edge it's very very hard balance to
strike this is something um I'm
struggling with if you were to say
what's your biggest mental downfall at
the moment it would be the ability to
celebrate victories and I'm the one that
says you know we need to be set in the
metrics and I think that anyone that's
in my position it's very easy to be a
hypocrite it's very easy some of the
advice I give I can't take myself and
one of it is about celebrating small
wins and I've been good at it before but
I've also been terrible this weekend
event and Apollo we've got three and a
half thousand people sold out event and
in my mind
like people like you must be buzzing I'm
like I don't think I am because to me
one I want to make sure it goes well I
can't be happy until it's gone well and
even if it goes well and afterwards
people come up to me and go that's the
best you've ever spoken
in my head I'm like well what next and
I'm really I did it with a million
followers on Insta
you know I had a beer then the million
on Tick Tock these are the things I look
forward to for years
then
um third time bestseller my publisher at
harpercollins he goes you and Luke have
just done the exact same thing he goes
what he goes you should have celebrated
but instead you were relieved because
the idea of failing to you was such a
big thing you wanted to avoid that you
shouldn't feel a sense of relief when
you conquer things that you wanted to
conquer it's like you should be happy
and I think about this quite a lot
because I don't take stock of any
achievements or accomplishments and
where is what you always want to do is
have someone slightly above you similar
to the humility thing in Jiu Jitsu
they're always high about seeing when
you're a black belt there's someone
who's higher than yours black belt and
the gradings of black belt go on time so
if someone's a black belt now I can
never overtake him so that's impossible
but like I did a really cool show did
Manchester Apollo and then I was like
RPS and sold it out two nights in a row
and then I did the event in Apollo and
then they're like oh Peterson did that
and he added Wembley and I'm like [ __ ]
I'm not I'm not doing Wembley and you
know if I could only go back to 2018
James and knock him on the [ __ ] face
and be like hey mate you're doing 50
people at a venue now you're going to be
doing three and a half thousand soon
2018 James about [ __ ] oh you're gonna
have a million followers shut the [ __ ]
up you have three best-selling books
[ __ ] oh my God I can't wait to be 33 but
now at 33. I'm kind of like oh you know
and it is a difficult thing where
did this happen for you after Rogan
a little but not much a little bit not
much
um mostly because it was it's like a
step change I think in how you're
perceived or whatever within the
industry that you've got the stamp of
approval of the guy that's currently the
the leader but I learned about a term
called championship ring or it's gold
medal syndrome uh which is depression
and gold medal athletes yeah yeah yeah
well what do you do after you've done
one but I did mention one one of the
guys from trigonometry I took them out
the week before I went on and they were
going on Rogan the next day and we did
the ice bath in cold tub and went for
barbecue at Terry blacks and they were
going through vacillating through the
same emotions that I was about to the
next week so it's kind of funny to see
them six days ahead of me doing the
thing that I was about to go and do and
uh one of the guys mentioned I'm
concerned about this sort of gold medal
depression thing and I was like well
yeah but there's a reason that you've
got ten fingers and a championship ring
only fits on what
so the goal of going on and doing it is
to go and do it again like you know if
you're Gordon Ryan right and he's got a
couple more challenges for this year
maybe two more challenges I think and
then if he does those
there is no way that anybody could say
he's not the greatest Grappler that's
ever lived
okay well
if you've won this title for the first
time of Greater scrappler
how long can you hold on to it
can you do it for two years can you do
it for three years can you sustain it
without any injuries can you do it
flawlessly can you beat everybody in
under a minute there is always a next
level I think to get yourself to but
it's interesting I think it's important
for people to hear the challenges that
you would have that they will face as
well you know the guy that's sold all of
the tickets at the live shows and does
the thing for some reason despite the
fact that he literally wrote a book on
trying to be as grateful as possible and
celebrating small victories and he's got
this big Academy of people and he's
saying you lost you lost a pound this
week you've lost 10 pounds so far this
year congratulations this is something
that you should
is struggling to imbibe his own advice
and this is why the insights that
people that are genuinely writing
content and creating stuff from the
heart that's why they're valuable this
is the big difference I think between
somebody like yourself and somebody like
Brian Rose let's say who I think is
completely creating content exclusively
to try and get an effect I don't think
that he's personally invested and I
watched one video from him
a few years ago and I've been very
public of my distaste for Brian online
and I know that you've been on his
podcast so you don't you don't need to
comment but
I saw a video from him talking about his
alcohol addiction
and he'd face the camera and he's
walking around near
bethanol green or something like that
and he is genuinely opening up about the
fact that he struggled with uh alcohol
daily for a decade maybe maybe multiple
decades and I was like if this was what
this guy's content was like all the time
Not only would I not be a hater I would
be a genuine fan this feels like him
opening up this is evidently something
which not only is valuable but is
something that is super super personal
to him this is this is a different
version of this man
so my point being when people do things
I think it's very important for those
that have got
positions of success on the come up to
continue to remind people that the
challenges that everybody else is facing
are still the ones that the people that
are leading the space are as well
I think that the and it sounds really
privileged to say this there becomes a
numbing effect the higher echelons you
go to because you become conditioned to
it like I even I flew first class about
a month ago when I sat there I wasn't
buzzing like I used to and I was like
James you [ __ ] piece of [ __ ] like
you were [ __ ] emotional the first
time that you sat in business class you
had a glass of wine you sat there you're
like oh my God this is amazing I don't
even drink on them anymore I'm like oh
no I don't want to be tired when I get
to the other end I'm like this is the
[ __ ] Pinnacle of most business
people's lives so I kind of do have to
remind myself but weirdly this numbness
to success is making me Broody right to
have kids
because
part of me is like
you get you get kind of above the Power
Pit in a certain sense my life's great
or whatever and I kind of think like in
the next three to five years what would
be great would be the inclusion of kids
as a project as something to then not to
be constantly dissatisfied with the the
wins but to have something completely I
know I could be wrong by all means I
could be on a podcast in a few years ago
mate don't have kids but part of me is
like it I want to take things away from
venues Revenue all this thing and have
like a little project that can sit by
the side of it so I have my humility in
Jiu Jitsu and my ultimate project being
my kids and then I have business there's
just like one leg of everything so that
you can kind of like diversify your
attention to different things but yeah I
think that I don't know whether or not
it's
actually in there but the last couple
years I was like oh kind of getting a
bit Broody for that because you kind of
complete these these fields in you know
certain areas of podcasting whatever it
is but it's almost not real you know
what I mean it's not real the money
comes you spend it it's gone Boom the
podcast they come people listen they go
into like a library and then sometimes
you just want to make sure that you're
winning the right races because
ultimately what you don't want is to
have this Mega podcast Mega loads of
money but not have a family and the
little someone to share it with yeah
exactly yeah dude I think we're both in
a similar situation here I've been
saying people have been asking and do
you want to have kids and it's only been
the last two years probably that I've
genuinely been able to say that I can't
wait to become a dad genuinely cannot
wait to become a dad because all of this
time that you've spent working on
yourself and building yourself up and
helping other people to upskill their
world
and it's fantastic and fulfilling but
it's it doesn't feel as altruistic as
funneling all of that towards some tiny
little human that is your genetic
Heritage and one of my friends David
perrell was talking to me and he was
he's someone that's very very successful
he does rite of passage which is this
cohort based online course and it's it
makes a terrifying amount of money and
is very very successful and helps people
to enact their dream of becoming writers
online so it's fulfilling and all the
rest of it and we were out for dinner
and he said something along the lines of
I think I spent most of my 20s preparing
myself to become the father that I want
to be
and that is a beautiful way to look at
it even though you weren't doing it at
the time even though that was it was
your uh inefficiencies and fears of
self-worth and your desire to chase tail
and get drunk and do whatever all of
those experiences created a person
Downstream from that that is going to be
the sort of father that you want to be
and I think it's one of the
justifications you know for all of the
more 50.1 percent of women at the age of
30 and blah blah blah and all of this
sort of stuff there is a
non-small cohort of people for whom the
kinds of parents they will be in their
30s
are
orders of magnitude greater than what
they would have been in their twenties
and I think that me and you probably
fall into that camp
yeah I think it's kind of sad but now
listen you know sometimes when I listen
to entrepreneurs talk sometimes I feel
sorry for them it's really weird thing
like people that are so caught up with
money I think you're never going to love
anything as much as you love making
money and money that although it opens
up experiences whatever I was like I
really I look at them and I go I really
hope I never have that relationship with
money because you're probably like that
more than your kids or whatever but also
when people say like oh how do I even
know I like my kids you know I think it
was Alex hormones that guy him and Derek
my place more days talking about oh why
would you have kids that ruin your
productivity why would you have kids
with all this and part of me like I I
said this to a quite a wealthy person
the other day and I don't think he liked
it I said I'm wealthier than you you've
just got more money
and then I really didn't say well with
him and I was like I can't feel sorry
for people that are like that because
ultimately it's like the ultimate
sacrifice you know back in the day you
could like it's not your is that your
dog can you go and strangle it mate I'll
I'll take a free kick into its ass it's
the most yappiest you can tell it's a
Jack Russell right it's got bad dogs got
anxiety you know like back in the day
you could be like a Spartan warrior and
you're like the best thing we could do
is die in battle and now you can't even
do that properly because you know you
would just be sent off to some little
conflicts that's a political thing and
you die and it should be a waste now I
feel like the best way to fall on your
sword is to be like a proper good parent
I think that's not not far off homozy
and Layla when they came on Modern
wisdom they spoke
uh with a little bit more Nuance about
the position and they said that a lot of
what people are trying to do with kids
does Alex had read something about it
and it was in a nice framework six areas
service Legacy Improvement something
else something else something else and
he said we feel like we already get that
from the particular construct that we
have to our life now and that seems like
a more balanced version then it's going
to damage my productivity but one of
those may be the real one and the other
one may be the public facing version I
don't know which one's which but yeah I
think um
for me and you it from where we are now
which if you tell me this I guess if you
told either of this what five years ago
yeah man you're going to feel paternal
broodiness you're going to not not
actively hate kids or they're annoying
or they're the thing that stops your
business partner from being able to go
out on the Lash with you or whatever
that they were but you're actively going
to when you see one on holiday you go
like wow
pretty cool isn't he he's cool you spend
longer than you should grinning at them
and then the parents see you and you're
like
sorry because the nonce radar is like no
he's he's like he's cute he's cute I'm
not attracted to him
um but yeah another thing that you
mentioned earlier on was
uh alcohol and I brought it up to do
with Brian as well alcohol is bottle
confidence is something that I've heard
a lot of people talk about but I also
know that your relationship with
alcohol's changed a good bit recently
talk me through that
yeah you know what like um it it just
makes me feel like [ __ ] more than ever
and I'm not sure if that's physiological
or psychological and it's quite
interesting because now if I go back
through my Rugby pictures I've got a
beer in my hand all the time and I used
to drink heavily every weekend part of
me looks back now I kind of cringe
looking at my younger self going quite
James you were if I could just snap into
your life and go mate why are you
getting blackout drunk every one in
every seven days
um I still drink now but for the right
occasion like we finished the event the
other day I'll join a beer on right now
I'm cool but then we had a program host
Us in Belfast with that big feed and I
was like yeah I'll have some lines here
but then the dating taking alcohol out
the equation was another utility of
deprivation so
I ask people with dating apps I'm not
going to say I'm better than you because
I didn't use one
could removing dating apps make you a
more confident person if the answer is
yes you should consider to do it cool
now you're going on dates could removing
alcohol from that situation make you
more confident on dates it's kind of a
double-edged sword this one because in
essence it will make you have to do the
practice you need rather than alcohol
just masking it covering it up cool also
I have a big bit about this in my live
show where I talk about the effects of
drinking on dates where you meet someone
and you're like that that's not me one
drink you're like hey
[Laughter]
I'm enjoying myself then you have two
drinks and you're like I really should
stop judging a book by his front cover
and then by six drinks you're like wow
this is gonna work yeah and then the
next day you're like [ __ ] I shouldn't
have done that so like alcohol I think
there's a there's definitely a utility
of depriving it then JP's utility of
Declaration report so porn stops you
from going on dates because if you have
a wank there's no way you're dating
anyone for the next six hours I'll
probably pulled out more dates than I
have women and then when I go on dates
I've got a utility or deprivation of
drinking okay I don't drink blah blah so
yeah there's definitely
alcohol should be used kind of sparingly
I know you've done since as well of
sobriety but
I think that I'm in a happy relationship
now and that's a massive
um kind of benefit to not wanting to
drink because I'm kind of like what's
the point yeah and I know that uh Andrew
Tate jokes I remember just where he got
canceled he was like clubs are for
people to [ __ ] he's like you go there
you get drunk the dynamic is the men buy
the drinks for the women women flock to
the guys cool men get [ __ ] girls get
dick whatever dust is like his way of
his angling it then I was like [ __ ] he's
got a fair point I was like now that I
have a missus I wouldn't dream of going
to a club I'd be like what's the point
they're like oh you can get drunk and
dance I'm like yeah but what's the point
yes you know I have other things that
make me happy so uh yeah alcohol I think
is
sometimes nice relaxing but it's also
self-destructive and I think people do
need to appreciate that and
if you've got goals and Ambitions in
your life that you want to accomplish if
wanking dating apps and booze are
getting in the way of that you need to
eradicate them and you can always
reintroduce booze when you're in a happy
relationship or a marriage you can
always reintroduce porn even when you're
in that relationship you can always
you know reintroduce dating apps if
you've got nothing in your pipeline but
people do need to look into alcohols are
Crux that almost bypasses
confidence is a lot like Fitness you do
need to keep working and paying into it
otherwise it will go away and it'll
diminish you lose anything skills are
perishable John Danna has said that uh
Gordon mines coach and you never really
think about the things that you know
Define the skills even whether it's
playing darts or bowling or whatever
they perish over time they will diminish
over time so I think that you don't want
to come too reliant on alcohol otherwise
everything will seem more daunting sober
yeah alcohol is a buttress that a lot of
people rely on because they're scared of
being social sober and a lot of the
times I mean I've spoken about this
forever right this has been my thing for
a very long time the sobriety it was one
of the biggest most important changes
that I'd made in my life not because I
had a problem with drinking but because
I needed more time and money and
consistency and energy to spend on
things that I truly cared about there's
this quote from homozy actually I'm
gonna I'm gonna make a prediction about
one of the things that I think you may
end up dialing back in Future as well I
think that you'll end up being red
pilled about caffeine too I think that
you'll end up dialing that back as well
and this from homozy is after I'd done
500 days without caffeine this
absolutely nailed why I did it cycle
stimulants don't let them use you if you
can't function without them they've
stopped conferring a benefit
be able to stop and only use them when
you really know you can Crush off on off
on is typically good enough for most
I do love caffeine
I think it's probably as well because
um do you know what it sounds crazy to
say this I'm recreationally use drugs
all my life I went through a phase of
when I came off uh alcohol in my early
20s took MD when I took MD I was like
wow why have I drunk my whole life I
went through all these kind of cycles
and then you know that early phase of
coming into money and you're like oh you
know we'll get a bag in go somewhere
nice whatever it is but genuinely when
that caffeine hits me in the morning
it's not my favorite drug like because
my values are so leaning on productivity
and work and servicing like a good video
a good concept A good live video even
going in the Facebook comments on like
my group or whatever so I'm getting a
high from a drug and I'm being
productive I've got these two Realms of
like happiness and dopamine coming in
through it I'm like going out and
racking lines and partying I'm like no
no caffeine and productivity let's go
um so yeah I do appreciate that there's
definitely a dependence on it but I like
the dependence I don't want I don't want
that natural because it's not adding to
say
yeah but you know what who was it who
said find what you love and let it kill
you slowly yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
that's another one because that coffee
in the morning I love it that an alarm
and croissant little dip in the sea
Click Boom you know I'm in a better
position than I was before how long did
it take you to feel the benefits
I would say
about a month probably which is quite a
long time to put up with not having
caffeine but I realize I'm gonna do a
video on it soon I realized that
I didn't have varying degrees of
tiredness I just had varying levels of
caffeine concentration in my blood if I
was tired I would have more caffeine I
wouldn't look at the underlying question
of why are you tired and you spoke about
this before right that alcohol is
masking it's filling in all of the holes
that you're not developing within
yourself okay well caffeine is filling
in all of the holes that your sleep and
your rest and your parasympathetic work
isn't getting to you're not restoring
yourself like you shouldn't be tired at
3 P.M you shouldn't be tired at 11AM
there is something that it it shouldn't
be the case we managed to survive for
hundreds of thousands of years with this
makeup not being injected with caffeine
in the middle of the day oh maybe we had
biphasic sleep and we had a nap or
something [ __ ] off my point being you
shouldn't need to rely on it if and if
you need it to perform then it stopped
conferring a benefit I realized that I
didn't have
any understanding about what was good
for me in terms of my energy balance and
that
may be different for you because I think
that you have a genuine love for the
impact of caffeine and it's part of your
daily writing ritual but when I took it
out and then reintroduced it after 500
days if I I do around about three days a
week now is sort of my limit so that's
kind of easy for me to do but dude if I
have a training session with caffeine
now it is I mean blow the doors off it's
so good it's unbelievably good and it
was never like that before it was just
it was just a training session
you know in America and somewhere in
some places in the UK they've got this
kind of engine called rain Yes 200
milligrams 350 in America
oh yeah like that's that's ready again
so like the idea of having two 300
milligrams of caffeine and especially
like a sparring session I love it
because that much caffeine I start
sweating quick I become slippy and like
I like the aggression I'll catch like a
knee in the temple and be like do it
again
I love that uh energy I get from it
sometimes I do like the crashes because
the crashes I get on caffeine are the
only times I can fully relax or justify
it but this is just that this is just
the addiction talking and the worst
thing is when you get a modicum of
intelligence you can justify the
addiction better so yeah the caffeine
one is it's going to be a difficult one
for me to think about but you're right
it is completely masking the
shortcomings in energy which is
ultimately one of the most valuable
commodities
um and for me to have that as one of my
like wake up principles
I just love it like have you spent much
time in Australia never been
the coffee there I can't explain it to
you I was never a coffee stump I was
happy with my little Pine to latte from
Costa when I went to Australia I was
like my whole life was a light it's like
the first time I'd done MD and realized
that drinking wasn't as much fun at a
festival when you do Australian coffee
the bowel movements the come up the
density The Taste even the care and
attention they put into it I'm
definitely a dealer like I sound like if
someone proclaiming how good their
dealer is May honestly he's got the
rocket this week yeah he's got he's got
the absolute fire so yeah it's like um
Australian Coffee Culture we'll have
this even if you have a decaf probably
enough to get your guts going rather
that with some proper proper experience
we need to get we need to get you to
Australia because you were in Dubai for
a bit and I joked saying Dubai is great
for people that have never been to
Australia
yeah very nice I am one of the things
that I've kept on thinking about
throughout thinking about confidence and
reflecting on your book is the asymmetry
of what we see in ourselves and what we
see of others and that being a cause for
self-judgment so it's one of the reasons
that I think people who have achieved
external success it's important for them
to open up about what their internal
challenges are because we see our own
failures from a front row seat on a
daily basis right the tiny tiny little
nuances of all of the indecision and the
the complete failure that you have to
get up on time but you hit snooze this
morning no one nobody is going to know
about that but you'll know okay let's
add one to the Lost column and then you
you quickly checked your phone to see if
somebody had texted you or what I said I
wasn't going to check my phone before
9am but I know that I looked but I
didn't properly look and then you try to
excuse it and you know all of the things
like just endless numbers of failures
that you view from a front row seat and
yet all that you see of everybody else
even the people you that you're the
closest to uh the man infestation of
their actions you don't get to see the
vacillation that's going on inside of
their brain all of the flip-flopping
backward and forward between what I
could or would have should have done and
then take that one step further removed
to the people that you see online that
is most of the people that you see don't
see that many people day to day okay
well they're giving you the Highlight
Reel of only the stuff that they ended
up doing which is not all of the things
that they thought about and I think that
just realizing and it comes back to that
the bar is set unbelievably low because
everybody feels the same discomfort that
you do whenever they're faced with the
same things when it's warm and
comfortable on a Thursday evening and
you're laid on the couch watching
Netflix and you know that you're
supposed to go to training in an hour's
time everybody has the same lack of
desire to go there
everybody does and it is the bar is so
low for you to be in the cohort of
people that does the thing as opposed to
not doing the thing
I think the like best way to kind of
like the saying that we have more in
common than we do differences the vast
majority of everything humans have is in
common it's not differences and it's
kind of annoying that even when we point
the finger at race gender you know all
of the things that Hot Topics in the
woke Community we have so much in common
like we say we all want to lay in bed we
all want to scroll and get dopamine hits
on Tick Tock before we go to sleep we
all get horny we all even in loving
relationships can be sexually attracted
to other people we all then have that
internal conversation of being like you
know nope I shouldn't act on this I need
to be more long-sighted uh we're all
self-destructive when we drink alcohol
we you know like that we have so much in
common and yeah like you say sharing
these emotions and these ways that we
think is such a big step in it because
absolutely yesterday I was quite openly
I was tired I was grumpy and with
everything being shot for the Queen's
funeral it just kind of [ __ ] my mood I
didn't have a reason to get out but you
know depressed people don't get out of
bed I didn't have a reason to get out of
bed so made me feel depressed so then I
was like I was kind of like annoyed and
people like oh do you hate the queen I'm
like that's not what I said I've had my
options taken away from me and it's made
me feel like [ __ ] so I was like I'm just
gonna be open about it someone was like
oh why aren't you sad on my story
questions I was like she lived in 96.
I'm not going to be sad about it so I
kind of rant it a bit and just let out
this grumpy inside part of me and
someone messaged me going I like that
you yourself on socials I just bought
your book and I was like it was kind of
liberating because I think that it is
very easy for people to hide behind this
guys of hey here's all the productive
[ __ ] I did today and you know what one
of the strangely I don't usually respect
everything he says so much but garyvee
did a video where he was saying some
days I don't get out of bed and I was
like oh wow the guy who I assume in my
mind never stops saying that he has days
where he doesn't do anything I was like
it's pretty nice to hear that and I
thought to myself I need to be more
sharing about that so hey guys it's 4pm
I just woke up or whatever it is so you
can kind of show people that you're
normal as well that's the same as the
Brian Rose video I think it's someone
dropping the veil that seems to be
playing a character a lot of the time
and one of the problems that you have is
if you play that character too much then
any people talk about this I mean
there's video compilations of Andrew
Tate online saying four times that
Andrew take broke a character Colby
Covington's got the same thing that
these people are such personas that
people can't believe that they're people
inside of it there is no person hiding
under the Persona there is only the
Persona now but then there's the
opportunity because it's so unbelievable
they're trying to look for oh well this
is what he's actually like when he's at
home with the dog or whatever and yeah I
I think that it's important I think it's
important for people to see that the
others that they look up to or whatever
have got flaws or even just people that
they respect have got inadequacies that
they've got those some same fears Ali
abdall gave this really great example on
one of his courses he does this uh
part-time YouTuber Academy thing and he
said it's most important to teach people
that are three steps behind where you
are because when you're 10 steps ahead
you're not going to be able to remember
the challenges of the people that are 10
steps behind you and this is one of the
important principles I think of
continually I mean you've done it with
the books like if you spend time
learning about Fitness then you do a
book on Fitness and you needed to work
out values and you did a book on values
and you needed to work out how to
execute and you do a book on executing
those are the challenges that you're
learning about and the audience
presumably comes along for the ride and
maybe in 10 years time there's a book on
parenting or something like that because
that you know these are the challenges
but if in 20 years time you were to try
and write a book about the principles of
losing weight and muscle gain and fat
loss that's gone that's gone you've
ascended to bigger and better things so
and other people have the opportunity to
do this as well this is why it's so
important I think to have some sort of
not Apprentice but the opportunity to
teach people around you whether it's at
work or family members or friends or
whatever if they're developing something
to learn from them and whatever you're
developing as well do the same because
it gives you a purpose for the reason
that you're actually pushing forward
yeah I I was saying I do think about
that and it's interesting that I was I
joked well didn't joke I was just
hypothesizing what the next book would
be about I don't think it'd be parenting
for quite some years but there's a and
that Doctor Who's on Rogan this week
have you started listening to this one
gabo mate
is that the guy is your reference just
poor yes it is he's incredibly smart and
very interesting and I love some of his
stuff because Brett Weinstein actually
had a similar uh view site he had a book
that came out in maybe October last year
and he said a similar thing about babies
crying and keeping them close and not
letting them touch the ground but I
would love to do a project for men
because my followings really changed in
the last year I've gone from majority
female to majority men the majority of
young men and it's not because I'm a
sexist or a misogynist or the
patriarchal tyranny is that I've seen a
lot of young guys in the gym book
signings and this and when I'm with them
I can sense within a snapshot of meeting
me that they want my opinion on
something and it's often about traveling
it's often about leaving a job they
don't like and it's often I'll I'll be
training the gym young lad 21 will come
over and I see a version of my younger
self in them but I can't do that with
women because I don't know the struggles
quite so well
and I'm like what'd you do oh yeah I
work in Insurance might you like it and
they're like well no one's asking if
they like their job for a while and
they're like oh yeah it's okay I'm like
what do you want to do they're like
I kind of want to do this I'm like oh
why aren't you doing it and then I'm
like you got Mrs and then they're like
yeah and I'm like you're happy in your
relationship and they're like oh they
feel quite challenged and then I don't
tell them what to do but I kind of
answer their questions I was like it
sounds like you've only been with her
because you went to college together it
sounds like you don't want to do the job
you want to do and you've spoken about
Australia twice since we started talking
so maybe you should go back before you
too old and then I'll nudge him and go
uh best do it soon or before you know it
you'll have two kids and you'll be
living around the corner but the message
you don't want to be with and they leave
and I can kind of see their shell
shocked
and I'd love to do that as a project
because
I like you say there's it's very
difficult I can't speak on behind on
behalf of women that's why I want to
talk to men but it's quite difficult to
navigate this world as a man at the
moment and I think that
it is like a political landscape that
even having that agenda or saying that
narrative is
you know people assume bad things
straight away when I think the men
something I think the Jordan Peterson
said again if you create a happy men
you're going to make women happy
because Every Man Has a Woman around
them whether it's a mother or partner a
sister whatever it is and like um yeah I
think that would be something I'd love
to Voyage into I don't even know how
it'd look if I'll be honest when's your
when's your bloody book coming out uh I
was on the phone to Luke earlier on
today and he was he's going to continue
pushing me Pro I would I would maybe
start on it next year
um there's two options for it there's
one that's about the current mating
crisis and there's one that would be
lessons that I've learned like a Broly
12 rules for life type thing but more I
guess more me and uh just before you get
distracted on that we got pissed in a
diner in Austin and you gave me three
principles that ended up being found in
backbones of chapters in my new book you
got it in there it's the belief thing
and it's not that you haven't got the
[ __ ] time you can do 10 minutes a day
I don't see why you'd wait till next
year and like the people that listen to
your podcast
what I've come to realize is getting
people to listen to Long format content
is [ __ ] difficult but they're doing
it for you and there are different
mediums that people like to absorb
content I found myself I used to listen
to audiobooks now I'm in a position
where I actually love getting a physical
book and taking it away from
distractions so I bought three books
um I've got Adam Grant think again you
read that no I think he might recommend
it to me there's one about
um distractions I can't remember what
it's called and I've actually been
recommended a book by a feminist so I
can't remember her name either not the
case against the sexual Revolution is it
no but this is for me to very much get
in bed with my opposing thoughts so my
my uh editor at hob college she goes
you're not gonna like this but you
should [ __ ] read it I was like okay
but I bought them in physical form I'm
going to Dubai in about a month I'm
going to take these books away from my
environment and just read them and for
people that watch your YouTube content
or absorb your podcast or whatever you
should give them the opportunity to take
something physical away from this
competitive online domain so that they
can absorb these lessons and rules for
life because
I'm relatively well read but even some
of the conversations we had Mia and Zach
changed the course of my life so if you
it seems to me you could be pushing it
off just to not have to deal with the
emotions of is this going to work is it
going to be successful are people going
to buy it you could just be the way you
challenge me with caffeine I'm going to
challenge you with a book
I think you're right man I mean
I there's definitely a fear of who the
[ __ ] am I to write a book and you and
Luke have pushed back against that a
hell of a lot
yeah I uh certainly seeing
you right yours has been a good
inspiration I think for me you know as
someone that's uh equally unqualified to
write books I think makes me
feel more uh empowered to go and do it
and the the most critical thing here is
that you don't need to embody a Persona
of anything you just need to stand on
the shoulders of giants and no one wants
any more than that even you know
sometimes I feel guilty for using
people's concepts for my own Advantage
but I'm like they didn't [ __ ] make
that up they read that in a book that
was older than them or it was a you know
something from a study or from whatever
it is and like even Gordon Ryan right
look at him right now best rapper in the
world hands down he's beating every
doubt I don't think he's lost the match
in five years he is only the best
because he stood on the shoulders of
John Donahue John Donna who's one of the
best coaches stood on the shoulders of
Enzo Gracie so this is always going to
go back you've just got to decide
whether or not you're going to stand on
the shoulders of all the guests you've
had in before or whether you're not
because it's very difficult to get
people to go back and listen to old
episodes because they don't want to hear
you talking about the beginning of the
pandemic in the beginning of the
pandemic so you know if you can take the
best bits and bring them together worst
case scenario it doesn't work out you've
learned something about your offering
and your client base and the people that
essential podcast which so there's a
utility to this even if it goes wrong
you are doing Luke's work for him mate
so yeah I I think that you're right and
I also agree with your point about
the the men conversation it's very
difficult online at the moment generally
for me especially because of the gender
Dynamics and The evolutionary psychology
stuff and it's on the it's on the edge
of red pill but it's also not quite it
doesn't quite align with the world view
that those people have so it gets
weaponized when it's useful and then it
gets people complain about it when it
doesn't agree with the Wolverine I'm
like look I'm not part of the [ __ ]
manosphere I'm not part of this red pill
thing can you explain red pill blue pill
Blackpool yeah sure so red pill is seen
as seeing the world for what it truly is
it's taken from the Matrix that would be
understanding The evolutionary
psychology precepts of mating Dynamics
it would be hypergamy from women that
date up and across its women want status
resources looks money that men
functionally should be chasing after
youth infertility that men are supposed
to have multiple partners that there is
uh the make value and women drop off at
the wall at the age of 30 and all of
this sort of stuff now they took a bunch
of stuff that I absolutely love in
evolutionary psychology my issue and
concern with red pill is that it doesn't
think about women and it doesn't think
about what they actually want it
considers them to be completely mutable
and meant to be immutable it's focused
more on changing women's preferences
than men's the blue pill would be
anybody that hasn't taken the red pill
so it's people who have a romantic view
of relationships they're going to see
true love as something that is possible
that you can have a partner that's going
to be with you forever that women aren't
going to be look to trade you in if you
lose status or lose money or do whatever
black pill are a group of men who see
the entire Pursuit as pointless it would
be tangential to mgtow which is men
going their own way
dating is pointless I am a genetic dead
end basically and any effort on my part
is going to be wasted so those are I
guess the no one would identify
self-identify as blue pill but red pill
and black pill are the two main areas I
suppose of the manosphere but I I just I
I don't think that either of them are
particularly useful
yeah it's interesting you'd think oh you
could probably have a red and blue
together Down the Hatch find your
perfect balance I had a so one of my
friends Coleman Hughes who you may have
seen who's on Rogan who's been on I
think he's been on Sam Harris as well as
this like uh dude from New York crazy
smart but also a rapper and a really
really good rapper as well also plays
classic trumpet or some [ __ ] uh it's
just like super it's way too clever and
way too competent and he did a
recreation of the scene from The Matrix
where Neo takes the red pill but instead
of it being Morpheus it was Neil
deGrasse Tyson and Neil deGrasse Tyson
offers him the red and the blue pill and
Coleman takes both of them and uh washes
them down together and then the music
videos start it's really funny
that is a pretty good way of saying that
because I I like to romanticize with the
blue pill ideology whilst being mindful
of the red pill ideology I think that
you know
if there are going to be trade-offs I
think that the biggest overarching
concept is that we can't appreciate it's
going to be easy
because blue pill is going to be
magnetized by red pill
and a lot of people's Red Bull
ideologies have been magnetized by blue
pill and I think that we we would all
love for it to be blue pill but then you
have got
valid points on both sides I think
actually no the blue Pro is more of an
ideology I mean because I looked at like
you know even some Peterson's beliefs
about how fan should be structured
marriage uh all of these things because
they are conducive and congruent to
Offspring I think red pill can sometimes
negate The Offspring in the Judgment as
well
and this even though you could say
family marriage is socially constructed
people don't ask themselves a question
enough for what
and you're constructing it not to you
know create Anarchy or chaos if you're
doing it to provide a stable upbringing
for kids and I think that
if some people want to be mindful of the
kids they're going to have you might
just have the blue pill
and doesn't say it's going to work
forever but I think yeah I I've got this
thing that I'm working on I might be
live streaming it may have happened by
now have you heard of snico do you know
who sneako is yeah yeah so I might be
live streaming with him at some point
soon and I want to put this idea across
to him of third wave manosphere so like
you've got first wave feminism second
wave feminism I think that we've seen
the first and second wave of the
manosphere come about so first wave was
Pick A Part history in the 2000s it was
Neil Strauss it was the game it was
mystery it was pickup it was
neuro-linguistic programming it was
negging it was that was the world and
then me too came around right and that
was just it was not going to survive the
Armageddon that metoo uh washed it away
with and maybe it shouldn't have done in
any case then the second version was a
much more sterilized version of pickup
and it was started by some of the people
that had maybe been in it some of the
language was similar but a lot of it was
different so instead of it being about
pickup and game it was red pill blue
pill Alpha Beta it was evolution
psychology and that very interestingly
to me
has moved on it's less whatever pickup
was which was [ __ ] crazy when you
actually look back at some of the advice
that was given in that which is I I
don't think uh particularly healthy
I still don't think that where we're at
at the moment is very functional because
it doesn't see men and women
fundamentally as allies it sees them as
adversaries it sees the relationship
between men and women as being zero-sum
that if a man beds a woman it's
literally her loss and his gain
hang on a second I thought that you were
trying to fix the instability that sex
positive feminism and all of these boss
[ __ ] leaning in and trying to go
their own way I thought that that was
what you're trying to fix this doesn't
feel like you're trying to fix very much
to me this seems like you're viewing the
opposite sex as an enemy that doesn't
seem like something that's very useful
so yeah I'm pretty sure that there is a
third wave manosphere to come about
which is more holistic more well-rounded
it sees women as compatriots rather than
as uh enemies and the other thing to
consider is there's way more
intra-sexual competition than into
sexual competition right competition is
between people of their same gender not
across genders but men and women don't
compete all that much they need each
other to keep going but they don't
compete they compete within their own
gender so yeah I there's a longer form
discussion to be had and maybe it'll be
with maybe it'll be out before now but
um look man let's bring this one home I
appreciate the [ __ ] out of you uh what
have you got coming up that people can
go and see are there any tickets for
anything left
uh Exeter in Dublin and then we've got
Sydney Auckland Christchurch and Dubai
so the there's some stuff going on there
just really keeping our socials if you
want to come along and spot your
interests come along but if not if they
follow me on socials they'll be in the
Honey Trap
James I appreciate you thanks man cheers
thanks for having me back what's
happening people thank you very much for
tuning in if you enjoyed that episode
then press here for a selection of the
best clips from the podcast over the
last few weeks and don't forget to
subscribe
peace
[Music]